[Music]
all right guys
i have a fun story for you and i'm sure
you're going to love it because i really
love it
i'll be the judge of that yes you let me
know if you love it i'll really dress a
lot do you love it
i love it i got it at ross
oh is that what the beginning of it was
i didn't remember that
yeah i just you just remembered i got it
that's all i remember
because yeah we would be like did you
[ __ ] it i [ __ ] it
i [ __ ] it at ross that's what we used
to say
it was junior high kids
you know that never had sex just so
stupid
yeah yeah so this story is about reuben
and reuben stuttered
such an old reference the sandwich
no american idol like season two or
something
yeah i love this story already i love it
i got it at ross so reuben tweeted this
out
he tweeted i can't believe i did it over
two thousand five hundred miles on a
bicycle thirty six days left my [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh mike you know where he went
he went from poo-poo point
to pee-pee creek that's amazing
it only took him 35 days 36 days
crazy because hugh only rode 69 miles a
day
i love it that's your [ __ ] i [ __ ]
it up
not one mile more not one mile less wow
69 miles a day wait so he could
so people could do it earlier than uh 36
days yeah crazy yeah
it takes less than a month on a bike
you're missing the point
you're missing it just blows my mind
that
you could get to the other side of
america in a month
in a month on a bike oregon trail
6.9 miles a day in 69 days
you're supposed to be immature right now
okay can you please dive into your
nine-year-old self
joe's complex okay don't put him in a
box like that all right [ __ ]
so here's reuben but it's like it's like
a naked weather girl that's saying that
it's going to be 120 this weekend and
her teeth are already like 120 degrees
that's really hot this weekend it's like
what am i supposed to do
all these errands to run [ __ ] my car's
gonna be so hot
[ __ ] you know why it's because you know
the oregon trail
like the actual oregon trail not the
game i want to do the oregon trail
on a bike on foot oh [ __ ]
on foot wow people do it on foot holy
moly are you going to wear shoes
yeah but now nah
how how long does that take on foot no i
want to laugh at you you've been choking
for months dude that's why i was like
how the [ __ ] did this dude do it in one
month well it did 69 miles a day
69 miles an hour that's a lot of miles
six days 2
500 miles poo poo point to pee pee pee
poo poo pee pee poo point who named it
poo poo point
and pp love this guy that's awesome so
not only that he's amazing because
this whole reason why he did this is to
bring attention to yemen
so he oh yeah so the crisis in yemen so
wait also before you say that he's
[ __ ] cute too she's his face
oh cutie pie yeah so he's a drummer and
i started stalking his ig i started
following him oh see you thought he was
cute too
uh huh i mean yeah yeah no i won't tell
him it's cool yeah don't tell him i'm
married it's weird i won't tell casey is
what i mean
no so he he decided to do all this so he
he can bring attention to the yemen
crisis so originally he wants to do
five thousand miles from oh my god
so a pee-pee creek to pee-pee island oh
my god i love it it's in canada
so currently he's still on the way we're
going to pee-pee
the island yeah then he should go to
there's um
there's a lake in south america it's
called lake titicaca
right between bolivia and peru oh so i
only know that because animania
oh because they did a song i thought
about it
right between bolivia and peru i don't
like to combine those two words
no me neither potato it's like
beauty and the beast they call it a
chili dog
where are you [ __ ]
on her chest and then titty [ __ ] yeah
that's disgusting it's clever i heard it
was called what did he eat
chili dogs this guy so he did everything
he did everything on a budget because
he's like
he's really he's he's broke and so like
i said he's a drummer so he's a musician
so he's broke he had planned to travel a
lot this year best time
but he couldn't and so that's when he
said that
he was like man it was crazy because so
he wrote little touring back
touring trip backstory i had so many
awesome tours lined up this year so
exciting for me then bam covered no
income had to stay with family became a
roofer worked
5 a.m to 8 p.m nearly 6 days every week
for 13 an hour save some money bought a
ticket and headed out
that's tight and yeah and then he was
like i've always been super frugal it
actually cost me near the same to be out
here and eating versus renting a room
for what
for whenever my next gig slash tour is
and eating
i plan to live it up and doing what i
want until my 30s where i am set on
becoming a music teacher no matter what
the end
that's dope wait what did he buy a
ticket for uh to get to
uh poo poo point oh just he started at
poopoo point yeah oh
i wish i knew where he was where's he
from do you know i was trying to find
out that too but
i couldn't find that answer i i think
i'm guessing he's from texas but i don't
know for sure
he's from [ __ ] balls texas no
no on the way to uh peepee creek
look check out where he stopped by
shorts road
shorts roads i love this guy
so well thought out i wonder if he's
sitting there on google maps looking for
a shark oh no no no that's too far
that was like a like just a funny coin
oh for real
yeah this is what his bike looks like
was he looking for poopoo creek and
peepee
road and pipi so he planned he planned
this trip ahead of time and he hit up
this organization that is
is providing aid to yemen and the whole
reason why
why he's so passionate about it is
because
due to the pandemic in yemen they
stopped receiving aid and there's a lot
of people starving
and so they there's like this crazy
intense yemen crisis going on
so he wanted to bring attention to it
like on his twitter
his name is like hashtag yemen can't
wait and so he's providing resources
that he actually had a fundraiser to
save up
our to fund raise money yes to raise
money
uh five thousand dollars for yemen that
was his initial goal
but it seems like he's oh he's surpassed
it now because the story has gotten so
much attention and he's not even done
yet because he's trying to go up to
peepee island as well but
this whole thing just went viral i don't
want to swim at peepee island though
why yellow smells bad
yeah i'm just afraid of cold water you
know what's false
that thing about if you pee in a pool it
turns blue
[Music]
that's not true it's like a urban urban
legend right they put chemicals and yeah
that that wasn't
it doesn't turn anything right no it
doesn't turn anything you just can you
just pee in there
i don't want to though do you pee in
pools i've peed in a pool
before and like in my you know like when
you're a little kid you hear about it
right don't pee in the pool it's gonna
turn blue and then one day i just really
had to pee and i was like
i let out a little bit and i was like
good to go
i only pee in public pools okay
not private pools i feel like everyone
only pees in public pools
yeah homies houses i don't like people i
should be everywhere
everywhere it didn't matter you ever put
you ever pee in the ocean i
only pee in the ocean but i like to take
my
pants all the way off and then like be
free while i'm [ __ ] paddling and then
pee and then i pull it back up is it
easy for you to pee
because like when i try peeing in the
ocean it takes me a long time me too
depends on how cold it is i'm like i
gotta pee
just [ __ ] get out i do want to take a
[ __ ] in the ocean
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you because
it could come back you don't know which
direction the [ __ ] title i mean all
the other animals are pissing me
or pissing everyone is [ __ ] and all the
fish come out and start eating it
oh yeah you guys should chilly don't
feel really fulfilled chewy dog in the
ocean
you guys owe me all right choked and
then i puke well you i don't know if you
guys were there i puked
on the sand yeah and then all of this uh
yeah we saw
all the [ __ ] fish oh
dude it came it was still gross were
people swimming nearby
uh my friends yeah everyone was swimming
nearby i don't know
because that makes sense though yeah
they couldn't wait
damn what about [ __ ] sharks
you guys do some kind of cross-country
trip like this yeah i would
that seems so freaking fun uh i'm more
of the driving type though
yeah same i'm gonna say that i'm like i
don't know about them riding a bike
across
i would do it if the bike didn't hurt my
[ __ ] gooch
you get over it i don't know you're
supposed to ride enough where you get
where it's nothing because i ride a lot
still but damn hey man i got to get a
different seat or something i'd be doing
that um
i used to have it airborne across
country airborne yeah you know a little
hoverboard yeah you don't want to do the
work is what you guys are saying yeah no
no i do want to do the work with my
ankle like this yeah that hurts
it hurts to get so sore autopilot that
[ __ ]
well what about if it's like not on a
road and then you can
go there's like routes where you they
have these trails
that you can go over mountains and all
that [ __ ] seems like that's what he did
because he google mapped it and he put
bike
and that's what it was and it said on
google maps
it said yeah i'm gonna go off-roading
across country
it was a nine-day trip like non-stop if
you do a bike
nine-day non-stop lost the whole country
what it would be
yeah well that's like biking 24 7 though
like non-stop
that's like no sleep 69 69 miles how
many hours is that
depends on how fast five miles an hour
if you do 12. if he was going 69 miles
an hour then it's like you know
an hour
that's 69 miles per hour yeah per hour
yeah 69 miles per day
it depends on how fast you're going it
does
yeah so like you go five miles you go
13. doesn't matter you'll probably do
the math with 36 days
there's the math equation there
somewhere for a lot of like legit
cyclists though that's like a two hour
workout
so that's like but he's taking his time
so
he's probably coasting yeah just having
a good time he's not like
[ __ ] he's not even looking at the
[ __ ] scenery oh wait so he did 69
miles
a day a day a day so and it took him 36
days
so if people that's the map so if he was
going
69 miles an hour that would take him 36
hours yes three days yes if he was going
that
fast yes is that even possible to go
that fast on a bike i doubt it
no 70 no way unless the whole thing's
downhill
because even those downhill guys they're
like 40
30. oh they're the ones with the [ __ ]
helmets right the elongated ones oh it
looks like a [ __ ] alien
you gotta change your tires and stuff
too riley girls just pop after like
a few thousand miles true sounds
dangerous too
i want to go over landing that that's
kind of like
off-roading what's that like flat flat
off-roading
i don't know just like exploring
exploring like
uh what's off-roading off-roading and
exploring yeah oh yeah yeah but then
like you stay out there
like and then usually the vehicles are
like
it's like an suv or what or like a van
but like you you
you have you can just camp on it like
you live on it
yeah he was saying that he would just
pull over once he was done with the 69
miles and just
find a spot and put up his tent really
he wasn't even staying in hotels
he wasn't doing hotels he was tensing it
up that's the best man he just he said
that he went through five
but five jars of peanut butter and then
he's burning way more than he can
consume
oh that makes sense yeah and he's also
said that his legs
his legs look like horse legs he's like
oh that's hot
damn i'm on a horse man like we like
sleeping in the forest you
just pull over and like knock out it
charges you up
better even though you sleep less hours
it sounds different still why you're an
interesting specimen i'm not gonna take
your word for it why is it
well my friends agree with me and they
did the same thing what do you mean
like there's no one there you tie up
hammocks
next to two trees that's safer than
anything i mean i guess
who what like a bird's gonna come and
bite your dick i felt like wild animals
yeah
there's like there's i can see bears
bears that's why you have a hammock
that's high they could climb
[ __ ] up they climb like crazy and they
[Music]
swim
[Music]
you